boneheads
he doesn't own it yet and he didn't
march down to the twitter headquarters
with duffel bags full of 44 billion
dollars and they signed it over to him
that is not how it works
holy actual [ __ ] how and how in the hell
how in the hell is it that the right
wing is just [ __ ] stupid they they
think elon musk now owns twitter because
they accepted his bid yesterday that was
the news the news was that twitter
accepted
elon musk bid
for
twitter
in other words elon musk put a bid in on
twitter
they took it seriously because elon must
show how he would pay the 44 billion
they took that seriously and they
accepted the bid
elon musk does not own twitter today
frankly
i'm of the belief and you can prove me
wrong you can go back and roll the tape
and say oh you were [ __ ] wrong
i actually don't i i still
i still am very skeptical that elon musk
won't flake on this deal
you know how many deals elon musk flakes
on this guy won't even [ __ ] sit for a
full haircut i'm gonna prove it
he flakes on his barber
for haircuts what makes you think he
might not flake on this deal
and besides they've just accepted his
bid what if there's another bid that
comes in
really [ __ ] stupid that
self-proclaimed free market capitalists
in this country have no idea the
difference between a public a private
corporation they have no idea that elon
musk isn't going to just own twitter
he's going to own the corporation that
owns twitter
they have no [ __ ] clue that he is
actually
subject to federal state laws civil laws
criminal walls like this is so [ __ ]
stupid
it's really [ __ ] stupid did you know
did you know it one time in in our
nation's history that twitter the
company twitter was private
the company twitter was private until it
released its ipo its initial public
offering back in 2013.
it was started and i think 2006 is when
twitter became a thing
and it wasn't until 2013 until they
released their ipo
and became public to to get financing is
the reason why they went public
is to increase the size of their
company instead of going to a bank
they went the route of an ipo and
released
public stock to buy parts of their
company
oh man
three weeks we're doing this elon musk
twitter blue balls [ __ ]
really is [ __ ] dumb
because elon musk and and again it's the
media the media out there oh [ __ ] he
bought it he didn't buy twitter yet
folks they accepted his bid
for the 44 billion
they accepted his offer
for the 44 billion he still has not
bought it yet there's a lot of [ __ ]
regulation and red tape to walk through
to take a company from being a pr a
public company like twitter is to being
a private 44 billion dollar
private corporation
and they have to follow all the laws all
the rules all the regulations they have
to do all that [ __ ]
again he's not gonna walk into the
twitter headquarters with duffel bags
full of 44 billion dollars and they just
hand him the keys and they all walk out
give me a [ __ ] break paige we are on
the books of face so if elon musk
destroys twitter we'll go i i don't know
everyone's like oh i'm gonna leave
twitter and i guess uh um i don't i know
his name i think it's talcum x he's a
rapper is that right i've never heard of
i think his name is sean king i've never
actually heard of heard of him before
i don't know i i'm not steeped in pop
culture but i i i don't know him but
apparently he already turned his account
off and of course the right wings
cheering because he left but
i mean i don't understand
what that means
i mean you left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter and they're happy
that he left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter yet it really is
[ __ ] dumb
does it does everybody know that elon
musk doesn't own twitter yet
he doesn't own it yet
it's not his yet he doesn't he's not
running [ __ ] over there yet
it's still the same twitter police that
was
before it's not the elon police it's
still it's still the same [ __ ] that it
was yesterday
all they did is say hey that 44 billion
dollars that looks like a nice stack of
cash that's that's basically what
twitter did yesterday
is that looks like a nice static and
i've been getting a lot of [ __ ] you
don't know how this works you don't know
how that works elon's buying it tony
doubt me
doubt me i'm not saying i'm right or
wrong i'm i'm predicting that the deal
falls through that's actually what i'm
predicting i think the deal falls
through i don't think i think the media
is getting all hyped up everyone on
twitter is getting all hyped up and
that's exactly that's exactly what elon
musk wants that's what he wants
that's what he's here for is to punk
your dumb ass
come on
that's what i think
uh lisa says sean king is a social
uh activist tony yeah that that may be
true i i haven't heard of sean i might
have heard of sean before uh stumble
crossing but when i seen the name this
morning i didn't recognize it i didn't
recognize it i think it's i think it's
really uh a dumb move
if he is an activist to not have a
microphone um you guys know
uh back when the joe rogan n word
controversy happened a lot of people
especially podcasters were were
boycotting spotify they were taking
their content down on spotify i will not
i will not
cower away from right wingers or nut
bags like elon musk i will not cower
away from them
if if really what he wants is freedom of
speech which is all [ __ ]
it's all bull he wants his freedom of
speech not everyone else's is what elon
musk means
let's face it
but i'm not gonna cower away from you
i'm not gonna cower away from spotify
i'm not gonna cower away from twitter
i'm gonna stay here and i'm gonna fight
that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be yelling and screaming until
the microphone they're gonna have to
drag me out of this hell hole to get me
off twitter for damn sure elon musk is
gonna have to grab me by the short and
curlies and open my
open the door with my head that's the
expression
telling you calm down everybody he
doesn't own twitter yet and he's a flake
he's a flake let me prove it here let me
prove it
i'll give you proof
i'm gonna show you proof this is this is
proof that he's a flake
i know this seems trivial
but this is true here's a picture of
elon musk
with a haircut look at this here i'll
make it bigger
he flaked on his haircut this is not a
finished haircut he did not even let he
did not even let
the barber finish his haircut look at
this guy
does this look like a guy that finishes
anything
come on
give me a break give me a break
oh
oh here brad brad's upset brad ford is
upset he said unsubbed apparently i'm
stupid eat [ __ ] if you stay on twitter
you're part of the problem bye brad see
you later dude
look if you're if you're upset about
speech
my speech especially if you're upset
about my speech especially well goodbye
see you later sayonara even brett says
adios goodbye
really this is dumb this is dumb if
you're gonna leave twitter then leave
[ __ ] it leave
go where where are you gonna go you're
gonna go to facebook oh you think you
think facebook isn't run by a
knucklehead
you think the metaverse isn't run by a
[ __ ] knucklehead
oh tick-tock oh that's much better over
there go over to tick-tock what about
instagram uh you know facebook owns
instagram can't go there where are you
gonna go you're gonna go to parlor
you're gonna gonna get her you're gonna
go to true social get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] come on get real get
real folks
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize
realize that elon musk has not bought
twitter yet
he's not
i'm predicting that he won't that's
right everyone's like oh he's he's
bought twitter he's bought it it's a
deal it's not a deal they just accepted
the bid
this is going to take months and months
and months to put this deal together and
this guy here on the screen well that
guy right there that guy right there
who couldn't sit for an entire haircut
and flaked on his barber here huh
flaked on his barber
this guy
this guy
isn't gonna flake on this deal come on
he's punking yeah he's punking and maybe
maybe um
jay says i'm still in denial i'm still
in denial which i mean that may be that
may be i i may have this delusion
that that elon musk doesn't flake on
things but he does he's been proven to
he said a lot of things that he was
going to do and really frankly i'm kind
of pissed off about the 44 billion
dollars
i am i'm really [ __ ] pissed off about
it here's why do you know do you know
what 44 billion dollars would do
for children
in schools do you have any [ __ ] idea
what 44 billion dollars could do
to feed hungry people in this country do
you have any [ __ ] idea
that's what we should be pissed about
that we are not taxing this [ __ ]
into oblivion
that's right if elon musk can afford to
buy a public company for 44 billion
dollars we should tax the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of him
that's what we should be pissed off
about this morning
if you're gonna be pissed off about
something don't be pissed off about he
owns twitter be pissed off that we
didn't tax him enough that that
[ __ ] can buy a private company
for 44 billion dollars
this guy can just [ __ ] out 44 billion
and he's bitching on tv on interviews
about us taxing him
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
so if you want to go
go
unsub leave i don't give two shits and
if you think i'm gonna give a [ __ ] and
not give my opinion on something your
your mistake you are in the wrong
[ __ ] place if you think i am
not gonna get my opinion on what i think
about politics or the social and
economical
position that our country's in
you have not been around long enough of
the tony michaels podcast you have not
that's for god damn sure